I'd roller today while appearing on Fox
and Friends former Speaker of the House
Newt Gingrich had harsh words for the
Muller investigation and the FBI's
tactics fact is that Rob Rosenstein has
not done his job he has not supervised
Muller this whole thing is an absurdity
we've now had one permanent Paul and
Paul Manafort and his wife in their
pajamas at 3 o'clock in the morning
having the FBI break down the door we
have had we've had this real last week
Cohen the lawyer have the door taken off
the hinges at 6:00 in the morning we're
supposed to have the rule of law it
ain't the rule of law when they kick in
your door at 3 o'clock in the morning
and you're faced with our men and you
you have had no reason to be told you're
going to have that kind of treatment
that's a that's Stalin that's that
that's the Gestapo in Germany that
shouldn't be the American FBI all right
as we continue what Joe did there
digenova and Professor Alan Dershowitz
these tactics are not American that's
the point this is this is what we expect
in Venezuela
this isn't not the United States or or
anything so my question to you what is
the president now do because I don't
think you can in good faith ever talk to
Robert Muller anymore I think that's
right look nobody should ever talk to a
prosecutor unless they have absolutely
no alternative no prosecutor is trying
to help a person who is a subject and
investigation just ask Martha Stewart
what happens when you talk to
prosecutors but he may it was horrible
yeah what was that lying to the FBI not
the underlying crime right right and
that's what happens and that's of course
why they want him to come and testify
because remember you can be charged with
perjury for telling the truth if
somebody else gives a contrary story and
the prosecutors decide to believe the
other person you can end up in a perjury
trap for telling the truth it's these
are unbelievable times I you know I
remember during the Clinton impeachment
people like professor Dershowitz Joe was
saying where's the sense of
proportionality where is the
prosecutorial discretion in a lot of
these things yes I I worry for the
country because the president no longer
can trust Muller
what is his legal team to
you hear cuz now I would argue they've
now got to go on offense and they've got
to make their case and they've got to
understand that it seems like there's no
topic that is off the table here well as
a result of the tactics authorized by
Muller and instigated by Muller in New
York with the raid of the Cohen office
and as a result of the manner in which
they raided the Paul Manafort home it is
now clear that Muller is acting in bad
faith that he has surrounded himself
with literally a bunch of legal
terrorists and that they are conducting
an interim grand jury they are not
interested in getting facts from the
President of the United States through
an interview they are trying to trap him
into a perjury trap or simply get
information that they can send the
Rosenstein to transmit to the House of
Representatives for impeachment those
are improper methods for seeking to to
question the President of the United
States the president should refuse to
cooperate with them completely
no more documents no testimony and if
necessary he should also change my next
question then take the fifth I don't
think he should take the fifth let me
don't lane why if he takes the fifth
they can give him immunity and then they
can compel him to testify and the
evidence can be used against me in an
impeachment proceeding because the
privilege against self relation doesn't
try in an impeachment proceeding so I
think it's a mistake but he could take
the sixth let me explain how he does
that what he says is I would love to
testify I have nothing to hide but my
lawyers have told me that under no
circumstances will they allow me to
testify I don't want to lose my lawyers
I have a right to be represented by
counsel and I have to listen to my
lawyer's advice what about Joe I laid
out look at the team that Muller is put
together why would anybody who's
supposed to be fair balanced and
objective ever higher Andrew Weissman
yeah well one of the most atrocious
records of any lawyer that I've ever
read about and frankly even Muller going
back to Boston and the anthrax case
these are not small cases here look let
me just say I agree with everything that
Alan said and and I just take a
different view of why
the president should take all legal
steps necessary to avoid testifying and
by the way agree with that if Muller
attempted to immunize him I happen to
believe that there are legal arguments
that would make the president not have
to comply with an order to make him
testify before a grand jury but let's
put that aside Muller is now has no
legitimacy the tactics that they have
chosen to use against a President of the
United States against whom there is no
evidence of a crime and never has been
from the beginning the use of those
techniques is has D legitimized this
investigation here's the other thing
that's going on
Robert Muller and rod Rosenstein and
Christopher Rea are doing mortal damage
to the institutions that they represent
the American people know what's going on
they're watching this and they are not
happy and I must tell you Robert Muller
I used to think was a decent guy and a
guy who had a great career he is
destroying his reputation through the
thuggish tactics which he is authorized
and through the people that he has
surrounded himself let me remind where
you drew Weissman nice remark yes sir
where this began let's go back in time
the Clintons were being investigated for
whitewater what did it end up with it
ended up with a perjury charge for not
disclosing an alleged sexual
relationship with a woman that had
nothing to do with the alleged
underlying crime and we allowed that to
happen and some of the same people who
are complaining today we're pushing that
kind of thing including some of the
Senators and Congress circumstances to
Joe I hear you trying to get it go ahead
no I'm just saying that I agree with
Alan and I think the one thing we
shouldn't do is repeat a mistake I just
have to tell you that what Bob Muller is
doing and has done is destroying the
Department of Justice and for Jeff
Sessions to sit there like a bump on a
log and do nothing about it
is disgraceful I think we all agree on
that and I would take it one step
further
I think Jeff Sessions engaged in
wrongful conduct by not telling the
president before
they never would have appointed I'm
driving a part-time Attorney General a
nice conversation saying I appreciate
your recusing yourself but I need a
full-time attorney job yep Jennifer to
be the Attorney General may be Jo or
maybe you professor all right guys thank
you very smart analysis our audience
needs to hear from both of you